investigation for the defense of the
president the issue of mayor Giuliani
has come up here in this chamber a lot
we thought it would be appropriate now
to turn to that issue the role of the
president's lawyer his private counsel
in this proceeding I would like to yield
my time mr. chief justice to Jane's
snoring Raskin mr. chief justice
Majority Leader McConnell members of the
Senate I expect you have heard American
poet Carl Sandburg summary of the trial
lawyers dilemma if the facts are against
you argue the law if the law is against
you argue the facts if the facts and the
law against you pound the table and yell
like hell well we've heard the house
managers do some table pounding and a
little yelling but in the main they've
used a different tactic here a tactic
familiar to trial lawyers though not
mentioned by mr. Sandberg if both the
law and the facts are against you
present a distraction emphasize a
sensational fact or perhaps a colorful
and controversial public figure who
appears on the scene then distort
certain facts ignore others even when
they're the most probative make
conclusory statements and insinuate the
shiny object is far more important than
the actual facts allow in short divert
attention from the holes in your case
Rudy Giuliani is the house managers
colorful distraction he's a household
name legendary federal prosecutor who
took down the Mafia corrupt public
officials Wall Street racketeers crime
busting mayor who cleaned up New York
and turned it around
a national hero America's mayor after
9/11 and after that an internationally
recognized expert on fighting corruption
to be sure mr. Giuliani has always been
somewhat of a controversial figure for
his hard-hitting take-no-prisoners
approach but it's no stretch to say that
he was respected by friend and foe alike
for his intellect his tenacity his
accomplishments and his fierce loyalty
to his causes and his country and then
the unthinkable he publicly supported
the candidacy of President Trump the one
who was not supposed to win and then in
the spring of 2018 he stood up to defend
the president successfully it turns out
against what we all now know as the real
debunked conspiracy theory that the
Trump campaign colluded with Russia
during the 2016 campaign the house
managers would have you believe that mr.
Giuliani is at the center of this
controversy they've anointed him the
proxy villain of the tale the leader of
a rogue operation their presentations
were filled with ad hominem attacks and
name-calling cold-blooded political
operative political bagman but I suggest
to you that he's front and center in
their narrative for one reason and one
reason alone to distract from the fact
that the evidence does not support their
claims so what's the first tell that mr.
Giuliani's role in this may not be all
that it's cracked up to be
they didn't subpoena him to testify in
fact mr. Schiff and his committee never
even invited him to testify they took a
stab at subpoena his documents back in
September and when his lawyer responded
with legal defenses to the production
the house walked away but if Rudy
Giuliani is everything
they say he is don't you think they
would have subpoenaed and pursued his
testimony ask yourselves why didn't they
in fact it appears the House Committee
wasn't particularly interested in
presenting you with any direct evidence
of what major mayor Giuliani did or why
he did it
instead they ask you to rely on hearsay
speculation and assumption evidence that
would be inadmissible in any court for
example the house managers suggest that
mr. Giuliani at the president's
Direction demanded that Ukraine announce
an investigation of the Biden's and
verismo before agreeing to a White House
visit they base that on a statement to
that effect by ambassador Sandlin but
what the house managers don't tell you
was that Sandlin admitted he was
speculating about that he presumed that
mr. Giuliani's requests were intended as
a condition for a White House visit even
worse his assumption was on third hand
information as he put it the most he
could do is repeat what he heard through
ambassador Volcker from Giuliani whom he
presumed spoke to the president on the
issue and by the way as mr. pora purpura
has explained the person who was
actually speaking to mr. Giuliani
ambassador Volcker testified clearly
that there was no linkage between the
meeting with President Solinsky and
Ukrainian investigations the house
managers also make much of a May 23rd
White House meeting during which the
president suggested to his Ukraine
working group including ambassadors
folker and Sandlin that they should talk
to Rudy the managers told you that
President Trump gave a directive and a
demand that the group needed to work
with Giuliani if they wanted him to
agree with the Ukraine policy they were
proposing but those words
directive and demand are misleading they
misrepresent what the witnesses actually
said ambassador Volcker testified that
he understood based on the meeting that
Giuliani was only one of several sources
of information for the president and the
president simply wanted officials to
speak to mr. Giuliani because he knows
all these things about Ukraine as
Volcker put it the president's comment
was not an instruction but just a
comment
ambassador Sandland agreed he testified
that he didn't take it as an order and
he added that the president wasn't even
specific about what he wanted us to talk
to Giuliani about so it may come as no
surprise to you that after the May 23rd
meeting the one during which the house
managers told you the president demanded
that his Ukraine team talked to Giuliani
neither Volcker nor Sunland even
followed up with mr. Giuliani until July
and the job July follow up by mr. Volker
happened only because the Ukrainian
government asked to be put in touch with
him Volcker testified that president
solinsky's senior aide Andrei Yermak
approached him to ask to be connected to
mr. Giuliani House Democrats also rely
on testimony that Mayor Giuliani told
ambassador's Volcker and soglin's that
in his view to be credible a Ukrainian
statement on anti-corruption should
specifically mention investigations into
2016 election interference and burries
MO but when ambassador Volcker was asked
whether he knew if Giuliani was and
these are his words conveying messages
that President Trump wanted conveyed to
the Ukrainians Volcker said that he did
not have that impression and he believed
the Giuliani was doing his own
communication about what he believed he
was interested in
but even more significant than their
reliance on presumptions assumptions and
unsupported conclusions is the managers
failure to place in any fair context mr.
Giuliani's actual role in exploring
Ukrainian corruption to hear their
presentation you might think that mayor
Giuliani had parachuted into the
president's orbit in the spring of 2019
for the express purpose of carrying out
a political hit job they'd have you
believe that Mayor Giuliani was only
there to dig up dirt against former Vice
President Biden because he might be
President Trump's rival in the 2020
election of course mr. Giuliani's intent
is no small matter here it's a central
and essential premise of the house
managers case that mr. Giuliani's motive
in investigating Ukrainian corruption
and interference in the 2016 election
was an entirely political one undertaken
at the president's direction but what
evidence have the managers actually
offered you to support that proposition
on close inspection it turns out
virtually none they just say it over and
over and over and they offer you another
false dichotomy either mr. Giuliani was
acting in an official capacity to
further the president's foreign policy
objectives or he was acting as the
president's personal attorney in which
case they conclude EPSA Dixit his motive
could only be to further the president's
political objectives the house managers
then point to various of mr. Giuliani's
public statements in which he is clear
and completely transparent about the
fact that he is indeed the president's
personal attorney there you have it
Giuliani admits he's acting as the
president's personal attorney and
therefore he had to have been acting
with
political motive to influence the 2020
election no other option right wrong
there is of course another obvious
answer to the question what motivated
mayor Giuliani to investigate the
possible involvement of Ukrainians in
the 2016 election the house managers
know what the answer is it's in plain
sight and mr. Giuliani has told any
number of news outlets exactly when and
why he became interested in the issue it
had nothing to do with the 2020 election
Mayor Giuliani began investigating
Ukraine corruption and interference in
the 2020 election way back in November
of 2018
a fall six months before Vice President
Biden announced his candidacy and four
months before the release of the Muller
report when the biggest false conspiracy
theory in circulation that the Trump
campaign had colluded with Russia during
the 2016 campaign was still in wide
circulation as the hill reported as
president Trump's highest profile
defense attorney the former New York
City Mayor often known simply as Rudy
believed the Ukrainians evidence could
assist in his defense against the
Russian collusion investigation and
former Special Counsel Robert Muller's
final report so Giuliani began to check
things out in late 2018 and early 2019
the genesis of mayor Giuliani's
investigation was also reported by
numerous other media media outlets
including CNN which related the
Giuliani's role in Ukraine can be traced
back to November 2018 when he was
contacted by someone he describes as a
well known investigator the Washington
Post and many other news outlets
reported the same information so yes
mayor Giuliani was president
Trump's personal attorney but he was not
on a political errand as he has stated
repeatedly and publicly he was doing
what good defense attorneys do he was
following a lead from a well-known
private investigator he was gathering
evidence regarding regarding Ukrainian
election interference to defend his
client against the false allegations
being investigated by special counsel
Muller but the house managers didn't
even allude to that possibility instead
they just repeated their mantra that
Giuliani's motive was purely political
and that speaks volumes about the bias
with which they have approached their
mission the bottom line is mr. Giuliani
defended President Trump vigorously
relentlessly
and publicly throughout the mother
investigation and in the nonstop conduct
congressional investigations that
followed including the attempted Muller
redo by the House Judiciary Committee
which the managers would apparently like
to sneak in the back door here the house
managers may not like his style you may
not like his style but one might argue
that he is everything Clarence Darrow
said a defense lawyer must be outrageous
irreverent blasphemous a rogue a
renegade fact is in the end after a two
years siege on the presidency two
inspector general reports and a 32
million-dollar Special Counsel
investigation turns out Rudi was spot on
seems to me if we're keeping score on
who got it right on allegations of FISA
abuse egregious misconduct at the
highest level of the FBI alleged
collusion between the Trump campaign and
Russia and suppose that obstruction of
justice in connection with the Special
Counsel investigation the score is Mayor
Giuliani for mister shipp zero but in
this trial in this moment mr. Giuliani
is just a minor player that shiny object
designed to distract you
senators I urge you most respectfully do
not be distracted Thank You mr. chief
justice
I yield back mr. Sekulow mr. chief
justice
members of the Senate house managers
we're going to now move to a section
dealing with the law to issues in
particular that my colleague Pat Feldman
the deputy White House Council will be
addressing issues involving due process
and issue specifically legal issues
dealing with the second article of
impeachment obstruction of Congress so I
will yield my time now mr. Chief Justice
to mr. Philbin mr. chief justice
senators Majority Leader McConnell
Minority Leader Schumer the other day as
we opened our presentation I touched on
two areas some of the due process
violations that characterize the
proceedings in the house and some of the
fundamental miss characterizations and
errors that underpin House Democrats
charge of obstruction and today I'll
complete the presentation on those
points to round out some of the
fundamentally unfair procedure that was
used in the house and its implications
for this proceeding before you now and
also address in detail the purported
charges of obstruction in the second
article of impeachment on due process
there are three fundamental errors that
infected the proceedings in the house
the first is as I explained on Saturday
the impeachment inquiry was unauthorized
and unconstitutional from the beginning
no committee of the house has the power
to launch an inquiry under the houses
impeachment power unless the house
itself has taken a vote to give that
authority to a committee I noted that in
cases such as Room Lee versus United
States in the United States versus
Watkins the Supreme Court has set out
these principles general principles
derived from the Constitution which
assigns authority to each chamber of the
legislative branch to the house and to
the Senate
but not to individual members or to
subcommittee's for an authority of the
house to be transferred to a committee
the house has to vote on that the DC
Circuit has distilled the principles
from those cases this way to issue a
valid subpoena a committee or
subcommittee must conform strictly to
the resolution establishing its
investigatory powers that was the
problem here there was no such
resolution there was no vote from the
house authorizing the issuance of
subpoenas under the impeachment power so
this inquiry began with nearly two dozen
invalid subpoenas the speaker had the
house proceeded on nothing more than a
press conference in which she purported
to authorize committees to begin an
impeachment power under the Constitution
she lacked that authority as the
chairman of the House Judiciary
Committee during the Nixon impeachment
inquiry pointed out Peter Rodino
explained that such a resolution from
the house has always been passed by the
house it is a necessary step if we are
to meet our obligations so we began this
process with unauthorized subpoenas that
impose no compulsion on the executive
branch to respond with documents or
witnesses and I'll be coming back to
that point that's threshold foundational
point when we get to the obstruction
charge the second fundamental due
process error is that the House
Democrats denied the president basic due
process required by the Constitution and
by fundamental principles of fairness in
the procedures that they used for the
hearings and I'm not going to go back in
in detail over those as we heard from
Judge Starr the House Democrats
essentially abandoned the principles
that have governed impeachment inquiries
in the house for over 150 years and I'll
touch on just a few points and respond
to a couple of points that the house
managers have made the first is that in
denying due process rights the house
proceedings were a huge reversal
from the physicians house Democrats
themselves have taken in the recent past
particularly in the Clinton impeachment
proceeding I believe we have manager
Nadler description of what was required
manager Nadler was explaining that due
process requires at a minimum notice of
the charges against you the right to be
represented by counsel the right to
cross-examine witnesses against you and
the right to present evidence all of
those rights were denied to the
president now one of the responses that
the managers have made to the defect
that we pointed out in the secret
proceedings where manager Schiff began
these hearings in the basement bunker is
that well that was really just best
investigative practice they were
operating like a grand jury don't be
fooled by that but those hearings
operated nothing like a grand jury a
grand jury has secrecy primarily for two
reasons to protect the direction of the
investigation so others won't know what
witnesses are being called in and what
they're saying to keep that secret for
the prosecutor to be able to keep
developing the evidence and to protect
the accused because the accused might
not ever be indicted in this case all of
that information was made public every
day the House Democrats destroyed any
analogy with any legitimate analogy to a
grand jury because that was all public
they made no secret that the president
was the target they should vial
calumnies about him every day and they
didn't keep the direction of their
investigation secret their witness lists
were published daily the direction of
the investigation was open and the
testimony that took place was
selectively leaked to a compliant media
to establish a false narrative about the
president if that sort of conduct had
occurred in
real grand jury that would have been a
criminal violation prosecutors can't do
that
under Rule 6 e of the federal criminal
rules it's a criminal offense to be
leaking what it takes place in a grand
jury and also the grand jury explanation
provides no rationale whatsoever for the
second round of hearings remember after
the basement bunker after the secret
hearings where the testimony was
pre-screened then the same witnesses who
had already been deposed were put on in
a public hearing where the president was
still excluded ask yourself what was the
reason for that in every prior
presidential impeachment in the modern
era where there have been public
hearings the president has been
represented by counsel and could
cross-examine witnesses why did there
have to be public televised hearings
where the president was excluded that
was nothing more than a show trial now I
also addressed the other day the house
managers contention that they had
offered the president due process that
at when things reached the third round
of hearings in front of the House
Judiciary Committee that manager Nadler
offered the president due process and I
explained why that was illusory there
was no genuine offer there because
before any hearings began other than the
law professors seminar in December 4th
the speaker had already determined the
outcome already said there were going to
be articles of impeachment and the
Judiciary Committee had informed the
counsel's office that they had no plans
to call any fact witnesses or have any
factual hearings whatsoever it was all
done it was locked in it was baked and
there was something else hanging over
that when they had offered purportedly
to allow the president some due process
rights and that was a special provision
in the rules for the House Judiciary
Committee proceedings
also unprecedented that allowed the
House Judiciary Committee to deny the
president any due process rights at all
if he continued to refuse to turn over
documents or not allow witnesses to
testify
so that if the president didn't give up
his privileges and immunities that he
had been asserting over executive branch
confidentiality interests if he didn't
comply was what the House Democrats
wanted then it was up to Chairman aller
potentially to say no rights at all and
there's a term for that in the law it's
called an unconstitutional condition
you can't condition someone's exercise
of some rights on their surrendering
other constitutional rights you can't
say we'll let you have due process in
this way if you waive your
constitutional privileges on another
issue the last point I'll make about due
process is this it's important to
remember the due process is enshrined in
the Bill of Rights for a reason it's not
the process is just an end in itself
instead is a deep-seated belief in our
legal tradition that fair process is
essential for accurate decision-making
cross-examine cross-examination of
witnesses in particular is one of the
most important procedural protections
for any American the Supreme Court has
explained that for over 250 years our
legal tradition has recognized
cross-examination as the greatest legal
engine ever discovered for the discovery
ever invented for the discovery of truth
so why did House Democrats jettison
every precedent and every principle of
due process in the way they devised
these hearing procedures why do they
devise a process that kept the president
locked out of any hearings for 71 of the
78 days of the so-called investigation
I'd submit because the process was never
about finding the truth the process was
about achieving a predetermined outcome
on a timetable and having it done by
Christmas and that is what they achieved
now the third fundamental due process
error is that the whole foundation of
these proceedings was also tainted
beyond repair because an interested fact
witness supervised and limited the
course of the factual discovery the
course of the hearings and I explained
the other day that manager Schiff had a
reason potentially because of his
office's contact with the so called
whistleblower and what was discussed and
how the complaint was framed which all
remained secret to limit inquiry into
that which is relevant the whistleblower
began this whole process his bias his
motive why he was doing it what his
sources were that's relevant to
understand what generated this whole
process but there was no inquiry into
that so what conclusion does this all
lead to all of these due process errors
that have infected the proceeding up to
now I think it's important to recognize
the right conclusion is not that this
body this chamber should try to redo
everything to start bringing in new
evidence bringing in witnesses because
the president wasn't allowed witnesses
below and redoing the whole process and
that's for a couple of reasons one is
first as my colleagues have demonstrated
despite the one-sided unfair process in
the House the record that the House
Democrats collected through that process
already shows that the President did
nothing wrong it already exonerates the
president but the second and more
important reason is because of the
institutional implications it would have
for this chamber whatever precedent is
set whatever this body accepts now as a
permissible way to bring an impeachment
proceeding and to bring it to this
chamber becomes the new normal and if
the new normal is going to be that there
can be an impeachment proceeding in the
house that violates due process that
doesn't provide the president
or another official being impeached due
process rights that fails to conduct a
thorough investigation that doesn't come
here with the facts established that
then this body should become the
investigatory body and start redoing
what the house didn't do and finding new
witnesses and doing things over and
getting new evidence then that's going
to be the new normal and that will be
the way that this chamber has to
function and there'll be a lot more
impeachments coming because it's a lot
easier to do an impeachment if you don't
have to follow due process and can come
here and expect the Senate to do the
work that the house didn't do I would
submit that is not the constitutional
function of this chamber sitting as a
court of impeachment and it should not
put this chamber should not put its
imprimatur on a process in the house
that would force this chamber to take on
that role now I'll move on to the charge
of obstruction in the second article of
impeachment accepting that article of
impeachment would fundamentally damage
the separation of powers under the
Constitution by permanently altering the
relationship between the executive and
the legislative branches in the second
article House Democrats are trying to
impeach the president for resisting
legally defective demands for
information by asserting established
legal defenses and immunities based on
legal advice from the Department of
Justice's office of legal counsel in
essence the approach here is that House
Democrats are saying when we demand
documents the executive branch must
comply immediately any assertions of
privilege or defenses to our subpoenas
are further evidence of obstruction we
don't have to go through the
constitutionally mandated accommodations
process to work out an acceptable
solution with the executive branch we
don't have to go to the courts to
establish the validity of our subpoenas
at one point manager Schiff said that
anything that makes the house
contemplate litigation is evidence of
obstruction instead the house claims
they can jump straight to impeachment
what this really means in this case is
that they're saying for the president to
defend the prerogatives of his office to
defend constitutionally grounded
principles of executive branch
privileges or immunities is an
impeachable offense if this chamber
accepts that premise that what has been
asserted here constitutes an impeachable
offense they will forever damage the
separation of powers
it will undermount undermine the
independence of the executive and
destroy the balance between the
legislative and executive branches that
the framers crafted in the Constitution
as Professor Turley testified before the
House Judiciary Committee facing
impeachment on this obstruction theory
would itself be an abuse of power by
Congress and I'd like to go through that
and unpack and explain some of that and
I'll start by outlining this three what
the Trump administration actually did in
response to subpoenas because there are
three different actions three different
legally based assertions for resisting
different subpoenas that the Trump
administration made and I pointed out on
Saturday there has been this constant
refrain from the House Democrats that
there was just blanket defiance blanket
obstruction as if it was as if it were
unexplained obstruction just we won't
cooperate without more and that's not
true there were very specific legal
grounds provided and each one was
supported by an opinion from the
Department of Justice's Office of Legal
Counsel so the first is executive branch
officials declined to comply with
subpoenas that had not been authorized
and that's the point I made at the
beginning there was no vote from the
house without a vote from the house the
subpoenas that were issued were not
authorized and I pointed out that in an
october 18th letter from the white house
council that specific ground
was explained and it wasn't just from
the White House Council there were other
letters on the screen now as of October
15th letter from OMB which explained
absent a delegation by a house rule or a
resolution of the house none of your
committees has been delegated
jurisdiction to conduct an investigation
pursuant to the impeachment power under
article 1 section 2 of the Constitution
and the letter went on to explain that
legal rationale not blanket defiance
there are specific exchanges of letters
explaining these legal grounds for
resisting the second ground a second
principle that the Trump administration
asserted was that some of these
subpoenas purported to require the
president's senior advisors his close
advisers to testify following at least
50 years of precedent the Department of
Justice's office of legal counsel
advised that three senior advisors to
the president the Acting White House
chief of staff the legal adviser to the
National Security Council and the deputy
national security adviser were
absolutely immune from compelled
congressional testimony based on that
advice from the office of legal counsel
the president directed those advisers
not to testify administration's of both
political parties have asserted this
immunity since the 1970s
President Obama asserted it as to the
director of office of political strategy
and outreach president george w bush
asserted it as to his former counsel and
to his White House chief of staff
President Clinton asserted it as to him
two of his counsels President Reagan
asserted it as to his counsel Fred
fielding and President Nixon asserted it
this is not something that was just made
up recently there's a decades-long
history of the Department of Justice
providing the opinion that senior
advisors to the president are immune
from compelled congressional testimony
and it's the same principle that was
asserted here and there are important
rationales behind
immunity one is that the president's
most senior advisors are essentially his
alter egos and allowing Congress to
subpoena them and compel them to come
testify would be tantamount to allowing
Congress to subpoena the president and
force him to come testify but that under
the separation of powers would not be
tolerable Congress could no more do that
with the president than the president
could force members of Congress to come
to the White House and answer to him
there's also a second an important
rationale behind this immunity and that
relates to executive privilege the
immunity protects the same interests
that underlie executive privilege the
Supreme Court has recognized executive
privilege that protects the
confidentiality of communications with
the president and deliberations is in
the executive branch is as the court put
it in the United States versus Nixon the
privilege is fundamental to the
operation of government and inextricably
rooted in the separation of powers under
the Constitution so the Supreme Court
has recognized the executive needs this
privilege to be able to function it's
rooted in the separation of powers as
Attorney General Janet Reno advised
President Clinton the immunity such
advisors enjoy from testimonial
compulsion by a congressional committee
is absolutely and may not be overborne
by competing congressional interest so
that's Attorney General Reno and
President Clinton this is not a partisan
issues is not a Republican or Democrat
issue administration's of both parties
assert this principle of immunity for
senior advisors and why does it matter
it matters because the Supreme Court has
explained the the fundamental principle
behind executive privilege is that it's
necessary to have confidentiality and
communications and deliberations in
order to have good and worthwhile
deliberations in order to have people
provide their candid advice to the
president because if they knew what they
were going to say
was going to be on the front page of the
Washington Post the next day or the next
week they wouldn't tell the president
what they actually thought if you want
to have good decision-making there has
to be that zone of confidentiality and
this is the way the Supreme Court put it
quote human experience teaches that
those who expect public dissemination of
their remarks may well temper candor
with a concern for appearance's and for
their own interests to the detriment of
the decision-making process
end quote that was also from United
States versus Nixon so those are exactly
the interests that are protected by
having senior advisors to the president
be immune from compelled congressional
testimony because once someone is
compelled to sit in the witness seat and
start answering questions it's very hard
for them to protect that privilege to
make sure that they don't start
revealing something that was discussed
so for a small circle of those close to
the president for the past 40 to 50
years administration's of both parties
have insisted on this principle now the
other night the house managers when we
were here very late last week they
suggested that executive privilege was a
distraction and manager Nadler called it
nonsense not at all it is a principle
recognized by the Supreme Court a
constitutional principle grounded in the
separation of powers they also asserted
that this immunity has been rejected by
every court that has addressed it as if
to make it seem that lots of courts have
addressed this they've all said that
this theory just doesn't fly that's not
accurate
that's not true in fact in most
instances once the president asserts
immunity for a senior advisor the
accommodations process between the
executive branch and the legislature
begins and there's usually some
compromise to allow perhaps some
testimony not an open hearing but in a
closed hearing or in a deposition
perhaps to provide some other
information instead of live testimony
there's a compromise
but the only two times it's been
litigated district courts it is true
rejected the immunity one was in a case
involving former counsel to President
George W Bush Harriet Miers
the district court rejected the immunity
but immediately on appeal the Court of
Appeals for the DC Circuit stayed that
decision and that decision means to stay
that District Court decision that the
appellate court thought there was a
likelihood of success on appeal that the
executive branch might succeed or to
minimum that the issue of immunity
presented questions going to the merits
so serious substantial difficult and
doubtful as to make them a fair ground
for litigation so the first decision was
stayed the second District Court
decision is still being litigated right
now it's the McGann case that the house
has brought trying to get testimony from
former counsel to President Trump Tom
began and that case was just argued in
the DC Circuit on January 3rd so there
is no established law suggesting that
this immunity somehow has been rejected
by the courts it's still being litigated
right now and it is an immunity that is
a standard principle asserted by every
administration of both parties for the
past 40 years asserting that principle
can't be treated as obstruction Congress
the third action that the president took
the administration took related to the
fact that House Democrats subpoenas
tried to shut out executive branch
counsel agency counsel from the
depositions of executive branch
employees now the office of legal
counsel concluded the congressional
committees may not bar agency counsel
from assisting an executive branch
witness without contravening the
legitimate prerogatives of the executive
branch and it attempting to enforce a
subpoena
while barring agency counsel quote would
be unconstitutional unquote
the president relied on that legal
advice here as Judge Starr pointed out
the president was consulting with the
Department of Justice receiving advice
from the very respected office of legal
counsel and following that advice about
the constitutional prerogatives of his
office and the constitutional
prerogatives of the executive branch
again administration's of both political
parties have recognized the important
role at agency counsel plays and the
Obama administration the Office of Legal
Counsel stated that exclusion of agency
counsel quote could potentially
undermine the president's constitutional
authority to consider and assert
executive privilege where appropriate so
why is agency counsel important as I try
to explain the executive privilege of
confidentiality for communications with
the president for internal deliberative
communications of the executive branch
those are important legal rights they're
necessary for the proper functioning of
the executive branch and agency counsel
is essential to protect those legal
rights when an individual employee goes
in to testify he or she might not know
probably would not know where is the
line for what's covered by executive
privilege or deliberative process
privilege not things that employees
necessarily know and their personal
counsel even if they're permitted to
have their personal counsel with them
same thing most personal attorneys for
personal employee for employees don't
know the finer points of executive
branch confidentiality interests of
deliberative process privilege and it's
also not their job to protect those
interests they're the personal lawyer
for the employee who's testifying trying
to protect that employee from potential
legal consequences we usually have
lawyers to protect legal rights so it
makes sense when there is an important
legal and constitutionally based right
at stake the executive privilege that
there should be a lawyer there to
protect
right for the executive branch and
that's the principle that the office of
legal counsel endorsed this also doesn't
raise any insurmountable problems for
congressional investigations or finding
information in fact just as recently as
April 2019 the House Committee on
Oversight and Government Reform reached
an accommodation with the Trump
administration after the administration
had declined to make someone available
for a deposition because of the lack of
agency counsel and that issue was worked
out an accommodation was made and there
was some testimony provided in other
circumstances so it doesn't always
result in the kind of escalation that
was seen here straight to impeachment
the accommodation process can work
things out
House Democrats have pointed to a house
rule that excludes agency counsel but of
course a house rule cannot override a
constitutional privilege so those are
the three principles that the Trump
administration asserted now I'd like to
turn to the claim that somehow this
assertion of these principles created an
impeachable offense the idea that
asserting defenses and immunities legal
defenses and immunities in response to
subpoenas acting on advice of the
Department of Justice is an impeachable
offense is absurd and it is dangerous
for our government let me explain why
House Democrats obstruction theory is
wrong first and foremost because in a
government of laws asserting privileges
and rights to resist compulsion is not
obstruction it's a fundamental right in
Bordenkircher versus Hays the Supreme
Court explained to punish a person
because he has done what the law plainly
allows him to do is a due process
violation of the most basic sort and for
an agent of the state to pursue a course
of action whose objective is to penalize
a person's reliance on his lead
Rights is patently unconstitutional this
is a principle that in the past and the
Clinton impeachment was recognized
across the board that it would be
improper to suggest that asserting
rights as an impeachable offense Harvard
Law Professor Lawrence tribe said quote
the allegations that invoking privileges
and otherwise in using the judicial
system to shield information is an abuse
of power that should lead to impeachment
and removal from office is not only
frivolous but also dangerous and manager
Nadler then said that the use of a legal
privilege is not illegal or impeachable
by itself a legal privilege executive
privilege and minority leader Schumer in
the Clinton impeachment expressed the
same view to suggest that any subject of
an investigation much less the president
with gay shion's to the institution of
the presidency is abusing power and
interfering with an investigation by
making legitimate legal creig claims
using due process and asserting
constitutional rights is beyond spurious
consideration and that was exactly
correct then and is exactly correct now
now more important than simply the
principle that asserting rights can't be
considered obstruction when the rights
the president is asserting are based on
executive privilege when they are
constitutionally grounded principles
that are essential for the separation of
powers and for protecting the
institution of the office of the
presidency to call that obstruction is
to turn the Constitution on its head
defending the separation of powers
cannot be deemed an impeachable offense
without destroying the Constitution
accepting that approach would do
permanent damage to the separation of
powers and it would allow the House of
Representatives to turn any disagreement
with the executive
/ informational demands into a supposed
basis for removing the president from
office it would effectively create for
us the very parliamentary system that
the framers sought to avoid because by
making any demand for information and
goading the executive to a refusal and
treating that then is impeachable the
house would effectively be able to
function with a no-confidence vote power
now that is not the framers design the
legislative and executive branches
frequently clash on questions of
constitutional interpretation including
about congressional demands for
information these conflicts have
happened since the founding in 1796
George Washington first president
resisted demands from Congress for
information about the negotiation of the
Jay Treaty and there have been conflicts
between the executive and the Congress
in virtually every administration since
then about congressional demands for
information the founding fathers
expected the branches to have these
conflicts
James Madison pointed out that the
legislative executive and judicial
departments must and the exercise of
their functions be guided by the text of
the Constitution according to its own
interpretation of it each according to
its own interpretation of it it was
recognized that there would be friction
similarly in Federalist 51 Madison
pointed out that the great security
against a gradual concentration of the
several powers in the same Department
consists in giving to those who
administer each Department the necessary
constitutional means and personal
motives to resist encroachment of the
others this is checks-and-balances this
friction is clashing between the
branches it is not evidence of an
impeachable offense it's the separation
of powers in its practical operation
it's part of the constitutional design
now the proper and historically accepted
way that these disagreements have been
resolved is through the constitutionally
mandated
accommodations process courts have
explained that the branches are required
to engage in an accommodations process
to resolve disagreements where there's a
clash over a demand for information as
the DC Circuit has explained when
Congress asked for information from the
executive branch that triggers quote an
implicit constitutional mandate to seek
optimal accommodation of the needs of
the conflicting branches end quote the
goal is to accommodate the needs of both
branches to reach a compromise if that
accommodation process fails Congress has
other tools at its disposal to address a
disagreement the house traditionally has
proceeded to contempt to a vote on a
contempt resolution in recent times the
House has taken the position that it may
sue in the courts to determine the
validity of its subpoenas and secure an
injunction to enforce them now the house
managers have pointed out that the Trump
administration when it was sued in the
began case in other cases taken the view
that those cases are not just disabled
in article 3 courts that's correct that
is the view of the Trump administration
that was the view of the Obama
administration and so there is that
resistance in the court cases to the
jurisdiction of the courts to address
those but I think house managers are
missing the point when they identify
that position that the administration
has taken because the house cannot claim
that they have a mechanism for going to
court they're in court right now
asserting that mechanism in the McGann
case and then simultaneously claim that
well they don't have to bother with that
mechanism they can jump straight to
impeachment impeachment under the
Constitution is the thermonuclear weapon
of interbranch friction and where there
is something like a rifle or a bazooka
at the houses disposal to address some
friction with the executive branch that
is the next step it is incremental ISM
in the Const
to ssin not jumping straight to
impeachment that is the solution if the
house could jump straight to impeachment
that would alter the relationship
between the branches it would suggest
that the house could make itself
superior over the executive dangle the
threat of impeachment over any demand
for information made to the executive
that's contrary to the framers plan
Madison explained that where the
executive and the legislative branches
come into conflict this is in Federalist
49 said quote neither of them it is
evident can pretend to an exclusive or
superior right of settling the
boundaries between their respective
powers unquote but that is exactly what
the house managers have asserted in this
case they have said that the house
becomes supreme there's no need for them
to go to court the executive must be
wrong any resistance to their subpoena
is obstruction if you claim that our
subpoena is invalid we don't have to do
anything to address that concern we will
just impeach you because resistance is
obstruction of Congress and the House
committee even put it this way in their
report the Judiciary Committee they said
that the house itself they effectively
have said that the house is the judge of
its own powers because what they said
was quote the Constitution gives the
house the final word end quote
that's on page 154 of the House
Judiciary Committee report and what that
is essentially saying they point to the
fact that article 1 section 2 gives the
house the sole power of impeachment and
they claim that because it's the sole
power of impeachment the courts have no
role the house is the final word it's
the judge of its own powers but that's
contrary to the constitutional design
there's no power that is unchecked in
the Constitution this sole power of
impeachment given to the house simply
means that that power is given solely to
the house not anywhere else the
Constitution does not say that the power
of impeachment is the Paramount power
that makes all other constitutional
rights and privileges and prerogatives
of the other branches fall away the
framers recognized that there could be
partisan impeachments there could be
impeachments for the wrong reasons and
they did not strip the executive branch
of any of its means for protecting its
own sphere of authority its own
prerogatives under the Constitution
those principles of executive privilege
those immunities still survive even in
the context of impeachment the power of
impeachment is not like the house can
simply flip a switch and say now we're
in impeachment and they have
constitutional kryptonite that makes the
powers of the executive eliminated so
when there are these conflicts even in
the context of an impeachment inquiry
the executive can continue to assert its
privileges and prerogatives under the
Constitution and indeed it must in order
to protect the institutional interests
of the office of the presidency and to
preserve the proper balance between the
branches under the Constitution
Professor Turley rightly pointed out
that by claiming Congress can demand any
testimony or documents and then impeach
any president who dares to go to the
courts House Democrats were advancing a
position that was quote entirely
untenable and abusive of an impeachment
and quote other scholars agree in the
Clinton impeachment Professor Susan low
block testified that quote impeaching a
president for invoking lawful privileges
is a dangerous and ominous precedent end
quote
it would achieve exactly the result that
guru nor morris one of the framers
warned against at the Constitutional
Convention
he explained that quote when we make him
referring to the president amenable to
justice however we should take care to
provide some mode that will not make him
dependent on the legislature end quote
that is exactly what this article of
impeachment would do
it would make the president dependent on
the legislature because any demand for
information made by Congress could be
used as the threat of impeachment to
enforce compliance by the executive and
the very theory that the House Democrats
have asserted is that there can be no
assertions of privileges no
constitutionally based prerogatives of
the executive to stand in the way if
that theory were true virtually every
president could have been impeached
virtually every president has asserted
at one time or another these
constitutional prerogative President
Obama famously in the Fast & Furious
investigation refused to turn over
documents that led to his Attorney
General being held in contempt
but that didn't lead to impeachment and
there could be a long list
professor Turley testified to be very
long list of presidents who would have
to be distinguished
if the principles being asserted now in
this case were applied to all past
presidents in history now the House
Democrats have given a few different
justifications for this approach but I
would submit none can be reconciled with
the Constitution they say that if we
cannot impeach the president for this
obstruction then the president is above
the law not so as I think I've pointed
out the president is staying within the
law asserting the law relying on the
legal advice from the Department of
Justice to make his arguments based on
long recognized constitutional
principles and indeed he is making the
fundamental point with respect to the
subpoenas that is Congress that is not
above the law it's the house the house
has to follow the law as well has to
issue valid subpoenas and if the law
isn't followed those subpoenas are null
and void and the executive doesn't have
to comply with them the House Democrats
say that they shouldn't go to the courts
because the courts have no role in
impeachment I think I've pointed out
that the House Democrats can't say that
they have this so just because of the
provision
the sole power of impeachment that it's
the paramount power and that no other
branch plays any role in providing a
check on how that power is exercised and
in addition the House Democrats have
gone to court in the McGann case that
they're litigating right now they have
asserted that that is part of the
impeachment inquiry the Trump
administration has explained that it was
not validly part of the impeachment
inquiry but that is the ground on which
they are litigating that they say that
they have no time for the courts I think
what that really means is they have no
time for the rule of law and the way
that they're pursuing the inquiry the
other day one of the house managers
actually said on the floor of the Senate
that they had to get moving they
couldn't wait for litigation because
they had to impeach the president before
the election that's not a valid reason
to not pursue litigation in the courts I
think it's relevant to bear in mind what
sort of delay are we talking about in
the McGann case that the house managers
referred to a number of times which they
had pointed out they presented as being
very long and drawn-out
they you should a subpoena in April but
they did not file a lawsuit until August
by November November 25th they had a
decision from the district court and it
was argued on appeal in the DC Circuit
in January third for litigation that's
pretty fast and it can go faster in the
Nixon case during Watergate the special
prosecutor issued a subpoena on April
18th 1974 on May 20th so in less than a
month the district court denied a motion
to quash the subpoena on May 31st the
Supreme Court agreed to hear the case
granting cert before judgment and the
Court of Appeals and on July 24th the
Supreme Court issued a decision that's
lightning fast so when the there is
urgency to the case when there is a
reason for it
there can be expedition in the courts
and a decision can be had
in timely manner in the one case that
actually arose from these impeachment
proceedings it was the house that
derailed the case this was the case
involving deputy national security
adviser Charlie Kupperman because when
he received a subpoena he went to court
and ask the court for a declaratory
judgment explaining what his obligations
were should he take the directive from
the president that he was immune and not
go or should he obey the subpoena now in
that case he filed suit on October 25th
the court within a few days set an
expedited briefing schedule but the
house withdrew the subpoena on November
5th just 11 days later in order to moot
the case so I think mitigation is a
viable Avenue along with the
accommodation process is a first step
then if the house believes that it can
go to court and wants to litigate the
jurisdiction and litigate the validity
that subpoenas that's also available to
them but impeachment as the first step
doesn't make any sense
and I should point out in part when the
house managers say they didn't have time
to litigate didn't have time to go to
the courts but they now come to this
chamber and say this chamber should
issue some more subpoenas this chamber
should get some witnesses that we didn't
bother to fight about what what do you
think will happen then that there won't
be similar assertions of privilege and
immunity that there wouldn't be
litigation about that again this goes
back to the point that I made if you put
your imprimatur on a process that was
broken and say yes that was a great way
to run things this was a great package
to bring here and we'll clean up the
mess and issue subpoenas and try to do
all the work that wasn't done and that
becomes the new normal and that doesn't
make sense for this body proper way to
have things handled is to have the house
if it wants to bring an impeachment here
ready for trial it has to do the
investigation the information it wants
to get if there's going to be resistance
that has to
be resolved and it has to be ready to
proceed not transfer the responsibility
to this chamber to do the work that
hasn't been done they also assert that
president Trump's assertion of these
privileges is somehow different because
it's unprecedented and it's categorical
well it's unprecedented perhaps in the
sense that there was a broad statement
that a lot of subpoenas wouldn't be
complied with but that's because it was
unprecedented for the house to begin
these proceedings without voting to
authorize a committee to issue the
subpoenas that was the first
unprecedented step that's what had never
happened before in history so of course
the response to that would be in some
sense unprecedented and this president
simply pointed out that without that
vote there were no valid subpoenas and
they have also been categorical refusal
in the past President Truman when the
House Committee on un-american
Activities in 1948 issued subpoenas to
his administration issued a directive to
the entire executive branch that any
subpoena or demand a request for
information reports or files of the
nature described and those subpoenas
shall be respectfully declined on the
basis of this directive and he referred
all such inquiries to the office of
president of the president for such
response as the president may determine
to be in the public interest and the
Truman administration responded to none
of them
a last point on the House Democrats
claim that the privileges simply
disappear because this is the
impeachment power of the house they have
referred a number of times the United
States versus Nixon the Supreme Court
decision suggesting that that somehow
determines that when you're in an
impeachment inquiry executive privilege
falls away well that's not true in fact
the United States versus Nixon was not
even actually addressing a congressional
subpoena it was a subpoena from the
special prosecutor and even in that
context the Court did not say that
executive privilege simply disappears
instead this court said quote it is
necessary to resolve these competing
interests they're the interests of the
judicial branch and administering a
criminal prosecution a case where the
evidence was needed these competing
interests in a manner that preserves the
essential functions of each branch and
it even held out the possibility that in
the field of Foreign Relations and
national security
there might be something approaching an
absolute executive privilege and that's
exactly the field that we're in in this
case Foreign Relations and national
security matters
another thing that you've heard is that
President Clinton voluntarily cooperated
with the investigation that led to his
impeachment produced tens of thousands
of documents but that's not really
accurate that was only after long
litigation again and again about
assertions of privilege he asserted
numerous privileges the House Committee
judiciary committee then explained quote
during the Lewinsky investigation
President Clinton abused his power
through repeated frivolous assertions of
executive privilege by at least five of
his aides and quote unlike the House in
this case Independent Counsel Starr
first negotiated with the White House
and then litigated those claims and got
them resolved ultimately the house
managers argue that all of the problems
with their obstruction theory should be
brushed aside and the president's
assertions of immunities and defenses
have to be treated as something to ferry
because if mr. Nadler put it only guilty
people try to hide the evidence that's
what he said last Tuesday night and mr.
Schiff similarly said in discussing the
assertion of the executive branch's
constitutional rights that quote the
innocent do not act this way end quote
really is that the principle in the
United States of America that if you
assert legal privileges or rights that
means you're guilty that the innocent
don't assert their rights that the
president can't defend the
constitutional prerogatives of his
office that doesn't make any sense at
bottom the second article of impeachment
comes down to a dispute over a legal
issue relating to constitutional limits
on the ability of the house to compel
information from the executive no matter
how House Democrats try to dress up
their charges a difference of legal
opinion does not rise to the level of
impeachment until now the house has
repeatedly rejected attempts to impeach
presidents based on legal disputes over
assertions of privilege as Judge Starr
pointed out in the Clinton proceeding
the House Judiciary Committee concluded
that the president had improperly
exercised executive privilege yet still
concluded that it did not have the
ability to second-guess the rationale
behind the president or what was in his
mind asserting executive privilege and
that you could not treat that as an
empirical offense it rejected an article
of impeachment based on Clinton's
assertions of privilege and as the House
Democrats own witness Professor Gerhard
has explained in 1843 president Tyler
similarly was investigated for a
potential impeachment his attempts to
protect and assert what he regarded as
the prerogatives of his office because
he'd resisted demands for information
from Congress professor Derrida
explained the tire's attempts to protect
and assert what he regarded as the
prerogatives of his
office for a function of his
constitutional and policy judgments and
they could not be used the Congress
determined to impeach him president
Trump's resistance to congressional
subpoenas was no less a function of his
constitutional and policy judgments and
it provides no basis to impeach him I'd
like to close with a final thought one
of the greatest issues and perhaps the
greatest issue for your consideration in
this case is how the precedent set in
this case will affect the future the
framers recognized that there would be
partisan and illegitimate impeachments
Hamilton expressly warned in Federalist
number 65 about impeachments that
reflected what he called quote the
persecution of an intemperate for
designing majority in the House of
Representatives and quote that is
exactly what this case presents and just
a story recognized that the Senate
provided the proper Tribunal for trying
impeachments because it was believed by
the framers to have a greater sense of
obligation to the future to future
generations not to be swayed by the
passions of the moment and one of the
essential questions here is will this
chamber adopt a standard for impeachment
and diluted standard that fundamentally
disrupts damages alters the separation
of powers in our constitutional
structure of government because that is
what both the first article for reasons
that Judge Starr and professor
Dershowitz have covered and the second
article the obstruction charge would do
and so I'll close just with a quotation
from one of the Republican senators who
crossed the aisle and voted against
convicting President Andrew Johnson
during his impeachment trial was Lyman
Trumbull who explained I think the great
principle that applies here he's
quote once we set the example of
impeaching a president for what when the
excitement of the hour shall have
subsided will be regarded as
insufficient causes no future president
will be safe and what then becomes of
the checks and balances of the
Constitution so carefully devised and so
vital to its perpetuity they are all
gone Thank You mr. chief justice
oh you too mr. Sekulow mr. Chief Justice
members of the Senate house managers mr.
Feldman
talked about the importance just
included on the importance of executive
privilege professor Charlie who
testified before the house said we have
three branches of government not two if
you impeach a president if you make a
high crime and misdemeanor out of going
to court it is an abuse of power
it's your abuse of power with regard to
executive privilege
it was mr. Nadler who said called it
executive privilege and other nonsense
when Attorney General Holder refused to
comply with subpoenas President Obama
invoked executive privilege arguing and
I quote compelled disclosure would be
inconsistent with the separation of
powers established in the Constitution
executive power and other nonsense
managership wrote that the White House
assertion of executive privilege was
backed by decades of president precedent
that has been recognized and has
recognized the need for the president
and his senior advisors to receive
candid advice and information from their
top aides executive privilege and other
nonsense the nonsense we talked about
this the other night is to treat the
separation of powers in constitutional
privileges as if they're asbestos in the
ceiling tiles
you can't touch them that's not the way
the Constitution is designed we can now
turn our attention to a separate topic
it's one that was been discussed a lot
on the floor here and will be discussed
now presenting for the president is the
former attorney general for the state of
Florida Pam Bondi she is also a
prosecutor a career prosecutor she's
handled countless cases she's going to
discuss an issue that the house managers
have put pretty much at the center of
their case and that's the issue of
corruption in Ukraine particularly with
regard to a company known as Purisima I
yield my time mr. Chief Justice to
former attorney General Pam Bondi
senators
[Music]
members of the Senate when the house
managers gave you their presentation
when they submitted their brief they
repeatedly referenced hunter Biden and
barista they spoke to you for over 21
hours and they referenced Biden or
barista over four hundred times and when
they gave these presentations they said
there was nothing nothing to see it was
a sham this is fiction in their trial
memorandum the house managers describe
this as baseless now why did they say
that why did they invoke Biden or burry
smih over 400 times the reason they
needed to do that is because they're
here saying that the President must be
impeached and removed from office for
raising a concern and that's why we have
to talk about this today
they say sham they say baseless because
they say this because if it's okay for
someone to say hey you know what maybe
there's something here worth raising
than their case crumbles because they
have to prove beyond a reasonable doubt
that there is no basis to raise this
concern but that's not what public
records show here are just a few of the
public sources that flagged questions
surrounding this very same issue the
United Kingdom Serious Fraud Office
Deputy Assistant Secretary of State
George Kent Hunter Biden's former
business associate an ABC White House
reporter Good Morning America ABC The
Washington Post The New York Times
Ukrainian law enforcement and the Obama
State Department itself they all raised
this issue we would prefer not to be
talking about this we would prefer not
to be discussing this but the house
managers have placed this squarely at
issue so we must address it let's look
at the facts in early 2014 Joe Biden our
vice president the United States led the
United States foreign policy in Ukraine
with the goal of rooting out corruption
according to an annual study published
by Transparency International during
this time Ukraine was one of the most
corrupt countries in the entire world in
Ukraine there's a natural gas company
called burry smih furry smih has been
owned by an oleg are named Macola sole
chefs key here's what happened
very shortly after Vice President Biden
was made us point man for Ukraine his
son hunter Biden ends up on the board of
burry smih working for and paid by the
oleg arc sole chatsky
in February 2014 in the wake of
anti-corruption uprising by the people
of Ukraine Zoll czev ski flees the
country flees ukraine so jeff ski the
oleg are is well known George Kent the
very first witness that the Democrats
called during their public hearings
testified sole chef ski stood out for
his self dealings even among other
oligarchs house managers didn't tell you
that ambassador Kurt Volker Vogler
explained that barrese Mahad a quote
very bad reputation as a company for
corruption and money laundering in quote
house managers didn't tell you that
barrese mo was so corrupt that George
Kent said he intervened to prevent US
aid from Co sponsoring an event Woodbury
smih you know what this event was it was
a child's contest and the prize was a
camera they were so bad parisa that our
country wouldn't even co-sponsor a
children's event with barrese MA
in March 2014 the United Kingdom Serious
Fraud Office opens a money laundering
investigation into the oligarch
sole chefs ki and his company furry smih
the very next month April 2014 according
to a public report hunter Biden quietly
joins the board of barista remember
early 2014 was when Vice President Biden
began leading Ukraine policy here's how
hunter Biden came to join briefs miss
board in April 2014 he was brought on
the board by Devin Archer his business
partner Devin Archer was college
roommates with Chris Hines stepson of
Secretary of State John Kerry all three
men hunter Biden Devin Archer and Chris
Heinz had all started an investment firm
together public records show that April
16th 2014
Devin Archer meets with Vice President
Biden at the White House just two days
later on April 18th 2014 is when hunter
Biden quietly joins Purisima according
to public reporting remember this is
just one month after the United
Kingdom's Serious Fraud Office opened a
money-laundering case into burry smih
hunter Biden joins the board and not
only 10 days after hunter Biden joins
the board British authorities seized
23 million dollars in British bank
accounts connected to the oligarchical
chefs key the owner of barista did
hunter Biden leave the board then no the
British authorities also announced that
it had started a criminal investigation
into potential money-laundering didn't
hunter buy and leave the board know what
happened was then only then did the
company choose to announce that hunter
Biden had joined the board after the
assets of buries m'a and is Oleg Ark
owners olschewski were frozen and a
criminal investigation had begun hunter
Biden's decision to join Purisima raised
flags almost immediately one article
from May 2014 stated the appointment of
Joe Biden's son to the board of
Ukrainian gas firm Purisima has raised
eyebrows the world over even an outlet
with bias for Democrats pointed out
hunter Biden's activities created a
conflict of interest for Joe Biden the
article stated the move raises questions
about a potential conflict of interest
for Joe Biden now even Chris Hynes
hunter Biden's own business partner had
grave concerns he thought that working
with Maurice 'ma was unacceptable this
is Chris Hines he was worried about the
corruption the geopolitical risk and how
bad it would look so he wisely distances
himself from hunter Biden and Devon
archers appointments to Purisima he
didn't simply call his stepfather
Secretary of State and say have a
problem with this he didn't tell us
runs hey guys I'm not getting on the
board I don't want nothing to do with
this he went so far as to send an email
to senior state Department officials
about this issue this is Chris Hines
he wrote apparently Devon and Hunter
have joined the board of Purisima and a
press release went out today I can't
speak to why they decided to but there
is no investment by our firm in their
company
what did Hunter Biden do he stayed on
the board what did Chris Heinz do he
subsequently stopped doing business with
his college roommate Devon Archer and
his friend hunter Biden Chris Hines
spokesperson said the lack of judgment
in this matter was a major catalyst for
mr. Hines ending his business
relationship with mr. Archer and mr.
Biden now the media also noticed the
same day an ABC news reporter asked
Obama White House press secretary Jay
Carney about it here's what happened
hunter Biden has not taken a position
with the largest oil and gas company
holding
me in Ukraine is there any concern about
least the appearance of a of a conflict
there see the vice president for you to
the vice president's office I saw those
reports
hunter Biden and other members of the
night and family are obviously private
citizens and where they work is not does
not reflect an endorsement by the
administration or by the vice president
or president but I would refer you to
the vice president's office the next day
The Washington Post ran a story about it
it said the appointment of the vice
president's son to a Ukrainian oil board
looks nepotistic at best
nefarious at worst again the appointment
of the vice president's son to a
Ukrainian oil board looks nepotistic at
best
nefarious at worst and the media didn't
stop questioning asking questions here
it kept going
here's ABC you have to fight the cancer
of corruption but then something strange
happens
just three weeks later a Ukrainian
natural gas company Purisima accused of
corruption appoints hunter Biden seen
here in their promotional videos to
their board of directors paying his firm
more than a million dollars a year
here's more from ABC continuing on
Ukraine wasn't the only country where
hunter Biden's business and his father's
diplomacy as vice president intersected
it also happened in China
this video shows Chinese diplomats
greeting Vice President Biden as he
arrived in Beijing in December of 2013
right by his side his son hunter less
than two weeks later hunters firm had
new business creating an investment fund
in China involving the
government-controlled Bank of China with
reports they hope to raise 1.5 billion
dollars in fact every witness who was
asked about hunter Biden's involvement
with Purisima agreed there was a
potential appearance of a conflict of
interest
multiple House Democrat witnesses
including those from the Department of
State the National Security Council and
others unanimously testified there was a
potential appearance of a conflict of
interest these were their witnesses how
much money did hunter Biden get for
being on the board
well you start looking at this bank
records according to reports between
April 2014 and October 2015
barista paid more than 3.1 million
dollars to Devin Archer and hunter Biden
that's over the course of a year and a
half how do we know this
some of Devin archers bank records were
disclosed during an unrelated federal
criminal case having nothing to do with
hunter Biden these bank records show 17
months the verismo wired to payments of
eighty three thousand three hundred and
thirty three dollars
not just for one month for two months
for three months but for 17 months
according to Reuters sources report that
of the two payments of eighty-three
thousand three hundred and thirty three
dollars each one was for Hunter Biden
and one Devin Archer hunter Biden was
paid significantly more than board
members for major u.s. fortune 100
companies such as Goldman Sachs Comcast
Citigroup the typical board member of
these fortune 100 companies we know
they're Titans of their industry they're
highly qualified and as such they're
well compensated even so hunter Biden
was paid significantly more this is how
well he was compensated so hunter Biden
has paid over eighty three thousand
dollars a month while the average
American family of four during that time
each year made less than fifty four
thousand dollars and that's according to
US Census Bureau during that time and
this is what's been reported about his
work on the board the Washington Post
said quote what specific duties hunter
Biden carried out for Buri smih are not
fully known end quote The New Yorker
reported quote once or twice a year he
attended briefs WA board meetings and
energy forums that took place in Europe
in quote when speaking with ABC News
about his qualifications to be unbury
smus board hunter Biden didn't point to
any of the usual qualifications of a
board member
hunter Biden had no experience in
natural gas no experience in the energy
sector no experience with Ukrainian
regulatory affairs as far as we know he
doesn't speak Ukrainian
so naturally the media has asked
questions about his board membership why
was hunter Biden on this board
if your last name wasn't Biden do you
think he would have been asked to be on
the board of Purisima I don't know I
don't know probably not so let's go back
and talk about his time on the board
remember he joined baristas Ford April
2014
while the United Kingdom had an open
money-laundering case against barista
and its owner the oleg arc saw chef ski
on August 20th 2014 four months later
the Ukrainian prosecutor general's
office initiates a money laundering
investigation into the same Oleg art so
chef ski this is one of 15
investigations into barista and zilch F
ski according to a recent public
statement made by the current prosecutor
general On January 16 2015
prosecutors pitches olschewski the owner
of Purisima on who's hunter Biden set on
his board on the country's wanted list
for fraud while hunter Biden's on the
board then a British court orders
sole chef skis 23 million dollars in
assets be unfrozen why was the money
unfrozen Deputy Assistant Secretary Kent
testified to it somebody in the general
prosecutor's office of Ukraine shut the
case issued a letter to his lawyer and
that money went poof
essentially paid a bribe to make the
case go away that is our strong
assumption yes sir he also testified
that the Ukrainian prosecutor general's
office his actions led to the unfreezing
of the assets after George Kent's
confirmation that prosecutor was out
Viktor shokhin becomes the prosecutor
general this is the prosecutor that
you'll hear about later the one that
Vice President Biden has publicly said
he wanted out of office in addition to
flagging questions about previous
prosecutors actions
George Kent also specifically voiced
other concerns this time to the vice
president's office about hunter Biden in
February 2015 he raised concerns about
hunter Biden to Vice President Biden's
office in a briefing call with the
national security staff of the office of
the vice president in February of 2015
I raised my concern that hunter Biden
status as a board member would create
the perception of a conflict of
interests but house managers didn't tell
you that this is all while hunter Biden
said on briefs miss board did hunter
Biden stop working for briefs m'a no did
Vice President Biden stop leading the
Obama administration's foreign policy
efforts in Ukraine no in the meantime
Vice President Biden is still at the
forefront of the u.s. Ukraine policy he
pledges a billion dollars loan guarantee
to Ukraine contingent on its progress in
rooting out corruption around the same
time with the 1 billion dollar
announcement other people raised the
issue of a conflict as special Obama
administration special envoy for energy
policy told The New Yorker it raised
hunter Biden's participation on the
board of Purisima he raised it directly
with the Vice President himself this is
a special envoy to President Obama and
the media had questions to December 8th
2015
the New York Times publishes an article
the prosecutor general Shokan was
investigating verismo
and its owner sole chef ski The Times
report here's their quote the credible
the credibility of the vice president's
anti-corruption message may have been
undermined by the association of his son
hunter Biden in quote with burry smih
and its owner
zilch f ski and it wasn't just one
reporter who asked questions about the
line
Maurice mah and the Obama administration
as we learned recently through reporting
on Fox News on January 19th 2016 there
was a meeting between Obama
administration officials and Ukrainian
prosecutors Ken Vogel journalists for
the New York Times asked the State
Department about this meeting he wanted
more information about the meeting quote
where us support for prosecutions of
verissimo holdings in the United Kingdom
and Ukraine were discussed in quote but
the story never ran around the time of
the reported story January 2016 meeting
between the Obama administration and
Ukrainian officials took place according
to a Ukrainian press report as
translated says quote the u.s.
Department of State made it clear to the
Ukrainian authorities that it was
linking the 1 billion dollars in loan
guarantees to the dismissal of
prosecutor general Viktor Shokan end
quote now we all know from the Obama
administration from the words of Vice
President Biden himself he advocated for
the Prosecutor General's dismissal there
was ongoing investigation into the oleg
article Chesky the owner of barista at
the time we know this because on
february 2nd 2016 the ukrainian
prosecutor general obtained a renewal of
a court order to seize the ukrainian
oligarchs assets a Kyiv Post article
published on February 4th 2016
says the Oleg our sole chef ski is quote
suspected of committing a criminal
offence of illicit enrichment end quote
over the next few weeks the Vice
President had multiple calls with
Ukraine's President poroshenko days
after the last call on February 4 24
2016 a DC consultant reached out to the
state
Department to request a meeting to
discuss barista we know what she said
because the email was released under the
Freedom of Information Act the
consultant explicitly invoked hunter
Biden's name as a board member in an
email summarizing the call the State
Department official says that the
consultant quote noted that two high
profile citizens are affiliated with the
company including hunter Biden as a
board member end quote
she added that the consultant would
quote like to talk with Undersecretary
of state Novelli about getting a better
understanding of how the u.s. came to
the determination that the country is
corrupt in quote to be clear this email
documents that the US government had
determined Furi psmith to be corrupt and
the consultant was seeking a meeting
with an extremely senior State
Department official to discuss the US
government's position her pitch for the
meeting specifically used hunter Biden's
name and according to the email the
meeting was set for a few days later and
later that month on March 29 2016 the
Ukrainian Parliament finally votes to
fire the prosecutor general this is the
prosecutor general investigating the
oligarch owner of verissimo on whose
board hunter Biden set two days after
the prosecutor general is voted out
Vice President Biden announces that the
US will provide three hundred and thirty
five million dollars in security
assistance to Ukraine
he soon announces that the US will
provide 1 billion dollars in loan
guarantees to Ukraine now let's talk
about one of the Democrats central
witnesses ambassador Jovanovic in May
2016
ambassador Jovanovic was nominated to be
ambassador in Ukraine here's what
happened when she was preparing for her
Senate confirmation hearing
congresswoman Stefanik had asked you how
the obama-biden
State Department had prepared you to
answer questions about barrese MA and
hunter Biden specifically you recall
that yes out of thousands of companies
in the Ukraine the only one that you
recall the obama-biden State Department
preparing you to answer questions about
was the one where the vice president's
son was on the board is that fair yes so
she's being prepared to come before all
of you all of you and talk about world
issues I'm going to be in charge of the
Ukraine and what did they feel the only
company the company that it was
important to brief her on in case she
got a question for isla ambassador
Jovanovic was confirmed July 2016 as the
Obama administration was coming to a
close in September 2016 a Ukrainian
Court cancels the Oleg article chap skis
arrest warrant for lack of progress in
the case in mid January 2017 verissimo
announces that all legal proceedings
against it and zultch F ski have been
closed both of these things happened
while hunter Biden set on the board
Aubry smih around this time Vice
President Biden leaves office years
later now former Vice President Biden
publicly details what we know happened
his threat to withhold more than a
billion dollars in loan guarantees
unless Shogun was fired here's the vice
president said I said I'm not gonna
we're not gonna give you the billion
dollars they said you have no authority
you're not the president the president
said I said call him
I said I'm telling you're not getting a
billion dollars I said you're not
getting a billion I'm gonna be leaving
here I think it was about six hours I
looked I said believing in six hours if
the prosecutors not fired you're not
getting the money Oh son of a [ __ ] got
fired and they put in place someone who
was solid at the time what he didn't say
on that video according to the New York
Times this was the prosecutor
investigating Purisima shokan what he
also didn't say on the video was that
his son was being paid significant
amounts by the oligarch
owner of verissimo to sit on that board
only then does hunter buy and leave the
board he stays on the board until April
20 19 now
November 20 in November 20 1990 Napa
David saying quote he's been unemployed
and has no other monthly income since
May 20 19 this was in November of 2019
so we know from after April 20 19 to May
20 19 through November 20 19 he was
unemployed by his own statement April 20
19 to November 20 19
despite his resignation from the board
the media's continued to raise the issue
relating to a potential conflict of
interest on July 22nd 2019 the
Washington Post wrote the fired
prosecutor general Shokan quote believes
his ouster was because of his interest
in the company in quote referring to
burry smih the post further wrote that
quote had he remained in his post he
would have questioned hunter Biden on
July 25th
20:19 three days later President Trump
speaks with president szalinski he says
the other thing there's a lot of talk
about Biden's son that Biden stopped the
prosecution and a lot of people want to
find out about that so whatever you can
do with this attorney general would be
great
Biden went around bragging that he
stopped the prosecution so if you can
look into it looks horrible to me in
quote the house managers talked about
the Biden's of recent four hundred times
but they never gave you the full picture
but here are those who did the United
Kingdom Serious Fraud unit Deputy
Assistant Secretary of State George Kent
Chris Ines the ABC White House reporter
ABC Good Morning America The Washington
Post The New York Times Ukrainian law
enforcement and the Obama State
Department itself they all thought there
was cause to raise the issue about the
Biden's and barista now the house
managers might say without evidence that
everything we just have said has been
debunked that the evidence points
entirely and unequivocally in the other
direction that is a distraction you've
heard from the house managers they do
not believe that there was any concern
to raise here that all of this was
baseless and all we are saying is that
there was a basis to talk about this to
raise this issue and that is enough I
yield my time
Thank You mr. chief justice Majority
Leader McConnell Democratic leader
Schumer house managers members of the
Senate this will be our last
presentation before dinner next Laurie
representing the president is Erik
Hersman he's a partner in the Kassovitz
firm a law firm which has been
representing the president for over two
decades
he's a former prosecutor and trial with
lawyer and he ran a natural gas company
in the United States he is going to
discuss additional evidence to house
managers ignored or misstated and how
other presidents might have measured up
under this new impeachment standard
mr. Chief Justice members of the Senate
I am Eric Hirshman I have the honor and
privilege of representing the President
of the United States in these
proceedings
I've been carefully listening to in
reviewing the house managers case that
case pretty much boils down to one
straightforward contention that the
president abused his power to promote
his own personal interest and not our
country's interests the house managers
say that the president did not take the
steps that they allege for the benefit
of our country but only for his own
personal benefit but if that's wrong if
what the President had wanted would have
benefited our country then the managers
have not met their burden and these
articles of impeachment must be rejected
as we will see the house managers do not
come close to meeting their burden
last week manager shift said that the
investigations President Trump
supposedly asked president szalinski
about on the July 25th call could not
have been in the country's interest
because he said they were quote unquote
discredited entirely the house managers
say that the investigations had been
debunked they were sham investigations
so now we have the question were they
really the house managers in their over
21 hours of the repetitive presentation
never found the time to support those
conclusory statements what is was it in
fact true that any investigation had
been debunked the house managers do not
identify for you who supposedly
conducted any investigations who
supposedly did the debunking who
discredited it wherein when were any
such investigations conducted when were
the results published in much war is
left unanswered our attorney general
Bondi went through for you some of what
we know about Purisima in its millions
of dollars in payments to Vice President
Biden's son in
Suns business partner there is no
question that any rational person would
like to understand what happened I'm
going to go through some additional
evidence which was easily available to
the house managers but which they never
sought or considered based on what
attorney general Bondi told you in this
additional evidence you can judge for
yourself whether the conduct was suspect
as you know one of the issues concerned
hunter Biden's involvement with the
Ukrainian natural gas company which paid
in millions of dollars while his father
was vice president and was in charge of
the Ukrainian portfolio during the prior
administration I'll get to those
supposedly discredited allegations
identified by the house managers in a
few minutes the other issue was what
managership called quote the baseless
conspiracy theory that Ukraine not
Russia interfered in a 2016 election
close quote
manager Schiff said that President Trump
wanted to quote erase from history
his previous political misconduct close
quote but there was no previous
political misconduct if any theory has
actually been discredited it's the
theory that President Trump colluded
with Russia in 2016 it was that theory
that was credited and discredited
entirely by mr. Muller's massive
investigation this same investigation
the Democrats demanded since President
Trump took office
this same investigation they knew they
were absolutely sure would expose such
collusion the same investigation which
after 22 months of exhaustive work at a
cost to the taxpayers of 32 million
dollars found no conspiracy in no
evidence of Russian collusion with the
Trump campaign and as we will see the
Democrats are as wrong now about the
articles of impeachment as they were in
2016
about the Russian collusion as to the
other incident
and Trump mentioned the one concerning
the Ukrainian gas company Purisima well
I actually think this is something that
is undisputed the Ukraine had a
particularly bad corruption problem
it was so corrupt that dealing with
corruption and solving the corruption
was a priority for our u.s. foreign
policy here is how one knowledgeable
observer of Ukraine put it in 2015
quote it's not enough to set up a new
anti-corruption Bureau and establish a
special prosecutor fighting corruption
the office of the general prosecutor
desperately needs reform the judiciary
should be overhauled the energy sector
needs to be competitive ruled by market
principles not sweetheart deals it's not
enough to push through laws to increase
transparency with regard to official
sources of income senior elected
officials have to remove all conflicts
between their business interests and
their government responsibilities now as
a general as Attorney General Bondi said
here are the facts we do know about
hunter Biden's involvement with Ukraine
verismo a Ukrainian natural gas company
paid hunter Biden millions of dollars to
serve on its board of directors he did
not have any relevant expertise or
experience he had no expertise or
experience in the natural gas industry
he had no known expertise in corporate
governance nor any expertise in
Ukrainian law he doesn't so far as we
know speak Ukrainian so why why did were
yzma want hunter Biden on its board why
did they want to pay him millions of
dollars well he did have one
qualification he was the son of the vice
president of the United States he was
the son of the man in charge of the
Ukrainian portfolio for the prior
administration and we are to believe
there is nothing to see here that for
anyone to investigate or inquire about
this would be a sham nothing to see here
but tellingly hunter Biden's attorney on
October 13th 2019
issued a statement on his behalf he
indicated that in April 2014 hunter was
asked to join the board of Purisima then
states hunter stepped off charisma board
in April 2000 19 now listen to the
commitment that hunter Biden is
supposedly willing to make to all of us
hunter makes the following commitment
under a Biden administration hunter will
readily comply with any and all
guidelines or standards a President
Biden may issue to address purported
conflicts of interest or the appearance
of such conflicts including any
restrictions related to overseas
business interests that statement almost
tells us all we need to know that's the
rule that should have been in place in
2014 because there already was in
obama-biden administration what changed
what changed remember a couple of
minutes ago when I quoted an expert on
Ukraine the one who said that Ukraine
must clean up its energy sector the one
who said that Ukraine's select senior
elected officials have to remove all
conflicts between their business
interests and their government
responsibilities you know said that
about Ukraine Vice President Joe Biden
in December of 2015
Vice President Biden went to Ukraine
approximately 12 to 13 times he spoke
with legislators businesspeople
officials he was purportedly fighting
corruption in Ukraine he was urging
Ukraine to investigate in uproot
corruption one thing he apparently did
not do however was to tell his son not
to trade on his family connections he
did not tell his son - especially stay
away from the energy sector in the very
corruption ridden country Vice President
Biden was responsible for it and manager
Shipp says move along there's nothing to
see here what are the house managers
afraid of finding out
in an interview with ABC in October of
last year hunter Biden said he was on
the board of our yzma to focus on
principles of corporate governance and
transparency bottom line is that I know
that I was completely qualified to be on
the board to head up the corporate
governance and transparency committee on
the board and that's all that I focused
on but when asked how much money Burr
yzma's was paying him he responded he
doesn't want to open his kimono in
disclose how much he does refer to
public reports about how much he was
being paid but as we now know he was
being paid far more than what was in the
public record you were paid $50,000 a
month for your position look I'm private
citizen one thing that I don't have to
do is sit here and open my kimono as it
relates to how much money I make or make
a deer didn't but it's all been reported
so what was the real reason that hunter
Biden the vice president's son was being
paid by Burr yzma was it based on his
knowledge and understanding of the
natural gas industry in Ukraine was he
going to discuss how our government
regulates the energy energy industry
here was going to discuss how we set gas
rates was he going to discuss pipeline
development construction or
environmental impact statements did he
know anything about the natural gas
industry at all of course not so what
was the reason I think we do not look
any do not need to look any further than
the explanation that hunter Biden gave
during the ABC interview when it was
asked why here's what he had to say if
your last name wasn't Biden do you think
he would have been asked to be on the
board of Purisima I don't know I don't
know probably not I don't think that
there's a lot of things that would have
happened in my life that that if my last
name wasn't fine and as if to confirm
how suspect this conduct was then it
should be a concern to our country
hunter Biden and his lawyer could not
even keep their story straight
the press release that was issued by BER
yzma on May 12 2014 with with hunter
Biden's lawyer statement on October 13th
of 2019 the May 2014 press release
begins are for Robert Hunter Biden will
be in charge of Holdings legal unit he
was going to be in charge of a Ukrainian
gas company owned by an oleg arts legal
unit however in his lawyer statement in
october of 2019
after his involvement with bir yzma came
under renewed public scrutiny he now
claims at no time was hunter in charge
of the company's legal affairs which is
it what was Hunter biting doing at
Purisima in exchange for millions of
dollars who knows
what were they looking to hide so much
for his corporate governance and
transparency but let's take a step back
and realize what actually transpired
because the house managers would have us
believe this had nothing at all to do
with our government nothing at all to do
with our country's interests nothing at
all to do with our vice-president
nothing at all to do with the State
Department it simply was private citizen
hunter Biden doing his own private
business it was purely coincidental that
it was in his father's portfolio in
Ukraine in the exact sector the energy
sector that his father said was corrupt
but we have a document here again
something that house manager house
managers did not show you or even put
before the house before voting these
baseless articles of impeachment if you
look at this email it's an email from
Chris Hines and as attorney Bondi
already told you he is the stepson of
the then Secretary of State John Kerry
and who was the other business partner
with hunter Biden in Devon Archer our
Secretary of State's stepson and our
vice president's son are in business
together it was sent on May 13 2014 to
the official government email
dresses of two senior people at the
State Department and who are these two
people the chief of staff to the
Secretary of State and the special
adviser to the Secretary of State the
subject line in the email is not
corporate transparency it's not
corporate governance it's not here's a
heads up the subject line is Ukraine
Chris Hoynes certainly understood the
sensitivity to our US foreign policy
in what does the Secretary of State's
Epps stepson say about hunter Biden
Devin Archer he says this apparently
Devin and hunter both joined the board
of Burr yzma and a press release went
out today I can't speak to why they
decided to but there was no investment
by our firm in the company what is the
most telling thing about this it is
clear that the chief of staff in the
special assistant to the secretary
already knew who Devin was because mr.
Heinz did not include his last name it's
just Devin and they obviously knew who
hunter was because again it's hunter
Biden this is Chris Hein saying I can't
speak to why they decided to join the
board of Purisima he's their business
partner not that there are good
corporate reasons and he's going there
going there for corporate governments
not that they're there to enhance
corporate transparency not that they are
there to further us policy not that they
are there to help fight corruption in
Ukraine not that they are there to
ensure that boards of directors
compensation and benefits are publicly
disclosed nothing like that he cannot
say those things because he knows devin
and hunter well and he knows they have
no particular qualifications whatsoever
to do those things especially for
Ukrainian gas company instead mr. Heinz
is plainly going on the record
to report what hunter and Devon were
doing through official channels to take
pains to disassociate himself from what
they were doing and what did the State
Department do with this information
that the Secretary of State stepson
thought they needed to know apparently
nothing they did not tell mr. Hines to
stay away they did not tell mr. Hines
there's no problem
nothing but all this the house managers
want us to believe does not even merit
any inquiry anyone asking for one anyone
discussing one is now corrupt does it
matter in an inquiry by a corrupt
company in a corrupt country would be
paying our Vice President son a million
dollars per year plus it appears some
additional expenses in paying his
business partner and additional million
dollars per year Secretary of carey's
Secretary of State Kerry stepson thought
it was important enough to report why
aren't the house managers concerned and
I ask you why would it not merit an
investigation and he knows something
else about Vice President Biden
well back in January of 2018 as you
heard former Vice President Biden
bragged that he had pressured the
Ukrainians threatened them indeed coerce
them into firing the state prosecutor
who reportedly was investigating the
very company that paid millions of
dollars to his son he bragged that he
gave them six hours to fire the
prosecutor or he would cut off 1 billion
dollars in u.s. loan guarantees said I
said I'm not gonna go or we're not gonna
give you the billion dollars they said
you have no authority you're not the
president the president said I said call
him
I said I'm telling you're not getting a
billion dollars I said you're not
getting a billion I'm gonna be leaving
here I think it was about six hours I
looked I said we leaving in six hours if
the prosecutors not fired you're not
getting the money Oh son of a [ __ ] got
fired and they put in place someone who
was solid at the time are we really to
believe that it was a policy of our
government to withhold a billion dollars
a billion dollars of needed guarantees
to in heed to Ukraine
unless they fired a prosecutor on the
spot was that really our policy we have
all heard continuously from the managers
and many agree about their risks to the
Ukrainians posed by the Russians we have
heard the managers say that a slight
delay in providing funding to Ukraine in
dangers our national security in
jeopardizes our interests and therefore
the president must immediately be be
removed from office yet they also argued
that it was the official policy of our
country to have hold a billion dollars
unless one individual was fired within a
certain matter of hours was that really
or could it ever be our United States
policy according to the house managers
theory we were willing to jeopardize
Ukrainians unless somebody who happened
to be investigating BER yzma was
promptly fired were we going to
jeopardize the Ukrainian economy because
a prosecutor was not fired in the 6-hour
time period
Vice President Biden demanded does
anyone really believe that was or ever
could be our United States foreign
policy in just in case the managers or
others try to argue no no no he wasn't
serious about that he was just bluffing
what kind of message would that send to
the Russians about our support for the
Ukrainians that we would Bluff in Bluff
with the Ukrainian economy from 2014 to
2017
Vice President Biden claimed to be on a
crusade
against corruption in Ukraine he
repeatedly spoke about how the cancer of
corruption was endemic in Ukraine in
hobbled Ukraine how Ukraine faced no
more consequential mission than
confronting corruption and he encouraged
Ukraine to close the space for a corrupt
middlemen who rip off the Ukrainian
people the vice-president railed against
monopolistic behavior were a select few
profit from so many sweetheart deals
that has characterized that country for
so long you known his last official
visit to Ukraine four days before he
left office he spoke out against
corruption in oligarchy that eats away
like a cancer and against corruption
which continues to eat away at Ukraine's
democracy within why was Vice President
Biden doing this was he so concerned
about corruption Ukraine even singling
out that country's energy sector because
corruption in Ukraine is a critical
policy concern for our country but
during this whole time what else was
happening his son and his son's business
partner were raking in over a million
dollars a year for what was regarded as
one of the most corrupt Ukrainian
companies in the energy sector owned and
controlled by one of the most corrupt
oligarchs were Vice President Biden's
words and advice to Ukraine just hallo
according to the house managers the
answer apparently is yes they were empty
words at least when it came to anyone
questioning his son's own sweetheart
deal his own son's deal with Ukraine's
corruption in oligarchy again to raise
manager shifts own question what kind of
message did this send to future US
government officials your family can
accept money from foreign corrupt
companies there's no problem you can pay
family members of our highest government
officials and no one is allowed to even
ask questions what was going on we have
to just accept now the house managers
conclusory statements
like sham discredited even though no one
has ever investigated why and can you
imagine what house manager Schiff and
his fellow Democratic representatives
would say if we were president Trump's
children on an oligarch Spey role and
when it finally appeared that a true
Ukrainian corruption fighter had assumed
the country's presidency President Trump
was not supposed to he was not permitted
to follow up on Vice President Biden's
own words about fighting corruption and
tried to make those words something
other than empty and according to the
house managers Ukrainian corruption is
now only a private interest it no longer
is a serious important concern for our
country now I want to take a moment to
cover a few additional points about the
July 25th telephone call in which the
house managers believe that the
president in the United States in their
words was shaking down in pressuring the
president of Ukraine to do his personal
bidding first of all this was not the
first telephone call that the president
of the United States had with other
foreign leaders so think about this for
a moment the call was routed through the
Situation Room it was a scheduled call
there were other people on the call
there were other people taking notes and
obviously the president was aware of
that fact the house managers talked
about the fact that the president did
not follow the approved talking points
as if the president any president is
obligated to follow approved talking
points and the last time I checked and I
think this is clear to the American
people President Trump knows how to
speak his mind but remember the fake
transcript that managership
read when he was before the Intelligence
Committee his mob gangster-like faked
rendition of the call well I prosecuted
organized crime for years the type of
description of what goes on would house
managers shift tried to create for the
American people
is completely detached from reality it
is as if we were supposed to believe
that mobsters would invite people they
do not know into an organized crime
meeting to sit around and take notes to
establish the corrupt intent manager
Schiff our jobs as prosecutors and I
know you were one would have been a lot
of easier if that were how it worked
think about what he is saying think
about the managers position that our
president decided with corrupt intent to
shakedown in their words another foreign
leader and he decided to do it in front
of everyone in a documented conversation
in the presence of people he did not
even know just so he can get this
personal benefit and was not that was
not in our country's interests the logic
is flawed it is completely illogical
because that is not what happened and
that is why managership ran away from
the actual actual transcript that is why
he created his own fake conversation but
I would like to just address another
point from the transcript of the July
25th phone call the house managers
allege that an oval office meeting with
the president was critical to the newly
elected Ukrainian president because it
would signal to Russia which had invaded
Ukraine in 2014 and still occupied
Ukrainian territory that Ukraine could
have could that I'm sorry that Ukraine
could count on American support they
actually argue that it was a quid pro
quo that the president would held this
critical oval office meeting that would
deter the Russians and save the
Ukrainians because he wanted something
personal now if that was in fact
critical to President Solinsky for the
safety of his own citizens he would have
immediately jumped at the opportunity to
come to the Oval Office
especially when President Trump offered
him that invitation during the July 25th
call but let's see what President
Solinsky actually says when he's invited
to Washington on that call he does not
say Oh
this is what I would like to do it's
critical for my people we will arrange
it immediately his response is I would
be very happy to come and would be happy
to meet you personally and get to know
you better
on the other hand I believe that on
September 1st we will be in Poland and
we could meet in Poland hopefully in an
oval office meeting if an oval office
meeting was critical to president
Solinsky
that was a time to say so not to suggest
another venue when we look at the
evidence that is before us it is clear
that the only people who talked about
having an oval office meeting were
lower-level government employees who
thought it was a good idea but the
principles involved those who actually
make the decisions
president Solinsky and president Trump
to them it was not critical it was not
material and it was definitely never a
quid pro quo what was important to
president Olinsky was not an oval office
meeting but delete the weapons that
President Trump supplied to Ukraine and
the sanctions that President Trump
enforced against the Russians that is
what the transcript of the July 25th
call demonstrates let us now consider
what President Solinsky knew about the
support that President Trump had
provided to Ukraine compared to the
support or more accurately a lack
thereof that the prior administration
had provided to Ukraine in February 2004
Russia began its military campaign
against Ukraine against the advice and
urgings of Congress and many in his own
administration President Obama refused
then and throughout the remainder of his
presidency to provide lethal assistance
to Ukraine in the house manager shift
joined many of his colleagues in a
letter-writing campaign to President
Obama urging that quote the US must
supply Ukraine with the means to defend
itself
close quote against Russian aggression
in urging President Obama to quickly
approve additional efforts to support
Ukraine's
efforts to defend its sovereign
territory including the transfer of
lethal defense weapons to the Ukrainian
military or March 23rd the House of
Representatives overwhelmingly passed a
resolution urging President Obama to
immediately exercise the authority by
Congress to provide Ukraine with lethal
defensive weapon system the very next
day this Senate passed a unanimous
resolution urging the President to
prioritize and expedite the provision of
defensive lethal and non-lethal military
assistance to Ukraine consistent with
United States national interest in
policies has one hit senator here stated
in March 2015
providing non-lethal equipment like
night-vision goggles is all well and
good but giving the Ukrainians the
ability to see the Russians coming but
not the ability to stop them is not the
answer yet President Obama refused he
refused even the face of support by
senior career professionals recommending
he provide lethal weapons to the
Ukrainians by contrast what a president
Solinsky and the Russians know they knew
that President Trump did did provide
that support that clearly was the most
material thing to him much more much
more than important important than a
meeting in the Oval Office the house
managers also make much of the
contention that President Trump
supposedly wanted president Solinsky
only to announce an investigation not
conduct anything but that content
contingent makes no sense president
Trump's call with President Solinsky was
in July of 2019 almost a year and a half
before our next election would only a
bear announcement so far in advance with
no follow-up really have had any effect
on the election as a managers claim
would anyone have remembered the
announcement a year or more later
ironically is the house managers who
have put burr yzma
connection to the Biden's front and
center in this proceeding and now the
voters will know about it and probably
we probably will remember it be careful
what you wish for
manager Schiff well there he goes again
he's putting words in the president's
mouth that were never there again look
at the transcript of the July call
President Trump never asks about any
announcement of any type of
investigation in President Solinsky
tells President Trump
quote I guarantee as the predator
president of Ukraine that all the
investigations will be done openly and
candidly that I can assure you what
happened next
the house managers say president Olinsky
did not want to get mixed up in US
politics but is precisely the Democrats
who politicize the issue last August
they began circling the wagons trying to
protect Vice President Biden and they're
still doing it in these proceedings they
contend that any investigation into the
millions of dollars of payments by a
corrupt Ukraine company owned by a
corrupt Ukraine oligarch - the son of
the second highest officer holder in our
land who was supposed to be in charge of
fighting corruption Ukraine they are
calling that type of inquiry a sham
debunked but there has never been an
investigation so how could it be a sham
simply because the house managers say so
which brings me to yet another one at
the house managers baseless contentions
that President Trump raised the matter
with President Solinsky because Vice
President Biden has just announced his
candidacy for president but of course it
was far from a secret that Vice
President Biden was planning to run what
had in fact changed first President
Solinsky had a bill had been elected in
April on an anti-corruption platform in
July running on the same platform his
party took control of the Ukrainian
Parliament that made it the opportune
time to raise the issue because finally
there was
receptive government in outre in Ukraine
committing to fighting precisely the
kind of highly questionable conduct
displayed by BER yzma in its payments to
hunter Biden and his partner just as Joe
Biden had raised years before to other
things in late June
ABC News ran a story entitled hunter
Biden's foreign deals did Joe Biden's
son profit off of his father's position
as vice president NJ then just a couple
of weeks before president Trump's
telephone call with President Solinsky
The New Yorker magazine
not exactly a supporter of President
Trump ran and expose will hunter Biden
jeopardize his father's campaign going
through some of the facts that we do
know about hunter Biden's involvement
with charisma in his involvement with a
Chinese company to New York reporter
again this was in July just a couple of
weeks before the phone call said that
some of Vice President Biden's advisers
were worried that hunter would expose
the Vice President to criticism a former
senior White House aide told The New
Yorker reporter that hunters behavior
invited questions about whether he was
quote leveraging access for his benefit
close quote
the reporter wrote that when I asked
members of Biden's staff whether they
did raise their concern with the vice
president several of them said they had
been too intimidated to do so everyone
who works for him has been screamed at a
former adviser told the reporter I don't
know whether anyone has been intimidated
by Vice President Biden or has been
screamed at by him about Purisima or his
son's involvement do we want the type of
government where questions about
facially suspect conduct are suppressed
or dismissed as illegitimate because
someone is intimidating or screams at or
is just too important no that is
precisely when an investigation is most
important
now last Thursday night manager Jeffries
provided us with a Democrat standard for
abuse of power he said quote abuse of
power occurs when the president
exercises his official power to obtain a
corrupt person Abednego ring or injuring
the national interest
mr. Jeffries and the house managers
contend that under this standard
president Trump has committed an
impeachable offense it must be
immediately removed from office
but if manager Jeffrey standard applies
then where were these same Democrats
calls for impeachment when
uncontroverted smoking-gun evidence
emerged that president obama had
violated their standard the American
people understand this basic notion as
equal justice under the law it is
American as apple pie yet the house
managers want to apply their own version
of selective justice here which applies
only to their political opponents they
want one system of justice for Democrats
in another system of justice for
everyone else but you do need you do not
need to take my word for it let's walk
through the facts on March 26 2012 on
the eve of the 2012 Nuclear Security
Summit in Seoul South Korea President
Obama met with Russian President Dmitry
Medvedev to discuss one of the pressing
issues in the United States national
security interest military defense how
important was the issue of millaa millaa
I'm sorry missile defense to the
strategic relationship between the US
and Russia as President Obama's defense
secretary Robert Gates said in June 2010
upgraded missile interceptors and
development quote would give us the
ability to protect our troops our bases
our facilities and our allies in Europe
gates continued there is nothing of the
minds on missile defense so there is no
meeting of the minds of mission on
missile defense
the Russians hate it they've hated it
since the late 1960s
they will always hate it mostly because
we'll build it and they won't during the
nuclear security summit President Obama
had a private exchange with Russian
President Medvedev that was picked up on
a hot microphone
[Music]
President Obama said on all these issues
but particularly missile defense this
this can be solved but it's important
for him to give me space
President Medvedev responded yeah I
understand I understand your message
about space space for you President
Obama this is my last election after my
election I will have more flexibility
President Medvedev responds I understand
I will transfer transmit this
information to Vladimir as we all know
is flat amir putin as you just saw in
2012 President Obama asked the Russians
for space until after the upcoming 2012
election after which he would have more
flexibility now let me apply mr.
Jeffries and the house managers
three-part test for abuse of power 1 the
president exercises his official power
President Obama's actions clearly meet
the test for exercising official power
because in his role as head of state
during a nuclear security summit after
asking President Medvedev for space he
promised him that quote missile defense
can be solved what else could that mean
but solved in a way favorable to the
Russians who were dead set against the
expansion of a US missile defense system
in Europe too to obtain a corrupt
personal benefit President Obama's
actions were clearly for his own corrupt
personal benefit because he was asking
an adversary for space for the express
purpose of furthering his own election
chances again President Obama said this
is my last election after my election I
have more flexibility President Obama
knew the importance of missile defense
in Europe but decided to use that as a
bargaining chip with the Russian with
the Russians to further his own election
chances in 2012 3 while ignoring or
injuring our Nash
interest as President Obama's defense
secretary said missiles would give us
the ability to protect our troops our
bases our facilities and our allies in
Europe surely sacrificing the ability to
protect our troops and our allies would
injure the national interest yet
President Obama was willing to barter
away the safety of our troops and the
safety of our allies in exchange for
space in the upcoming election in short
President Obama leveraged the power of
his office to the detriment of US policy
on missile defense in order to influence
the 2012 election solely to his
advantage and we never would have known
and President Obama realized that the
microphone was on that there was a hot
mic one could easily substitute
President Obama's 2000 exchange with
President Medvedev into Article one of
the houses of Pietschmann articles
against President Trump using the powers
of his high office President Obama
solicited interference of a former
foreign government Russia in the 2012
United States presidential election he
did through he did so through a scheme
or course of conduct that included
soliciting the government of Russia to
give him space quote-unquote on missile
defense that would benefit his
re-election in influence to 2012 United
States presidential election to his
advantage in doing so President Obama
used the powers of the presidency in a
manner that compromised the national
security of the United States in
undermined the integrity of the United
States democratic process he thus
ignored and injured the interests of the
nation close quote
does it sound familiar house managers it
should has the case against President
Obama would have been far stronger than
the allegations against President Trump
President Obama's abuse of power to
benefit his own political interests was
there and is here now for everyone to
hear it was a direct unquestionable
quid pro quo no mind-reading was needed
there where were the house managers then
and that points out the absurdity of the
house managers case against President
Trump it was President Obama not
president Trump who was weak on Russia
in week on support to Ukraine
President Obama caved to Russia and
Putin on missile defense when he decided
to scrap the u.s. plans to install
missile bases of Poland yet he
criticized senator Romney during the
2012 presidential campaign when Senator
Romney said Russia was the greatest
geopolitical threat to the US Governor
Romney I'm glad that you recognized that
al Qaeda is a threat because a few
months ago when you were asked what's
the biggest geopolitical threat facing
America you said Russia not al Qaeda you
said Russia and the 1980s are now
calling to ask for their foreign policy
back because you know the Cold War has
been over for 20 years now when it is
politically convenient the Democrats are
saying the same thing that Oh President
Obama criticized said under Romney for
saying in fact they are basing their
entire politicized impeachment on this
inversion of reality this claim that
President Trump is not supporting
Ukraine far more than the prior
administration President Obama caved on
missile defense in late 2009
his Hawk hot mic moment occurred in
March 2012 his re-election was eight
months later two years later in March
2014 Russia invaded Ukraine in annex
Crimea President Trump refused to
provide lethal aid to Ukraine to enable
it sorry
President Obama refused to provide
lethal aid to Ukraine to enable it to
defend itself where were the house
managers then the house managers would
have the American people believe that
there was a threat an imminent threat to
the national security of our country for
which the president must be removed
immediately from the highest office in
the land because what because he had a
phone call with a foreign leader and
discussed corruption because he paused
for a short period of time giving away
our tax dollars to a foreign country
that is their theory it is absurd on its
face not one American life was in
jeopardy or lost by the short delay and
they know it and how do we know that
they know it because they went on
vacation after they adopted the articles
of impeachment they did not cancel the
recess they did not rush back to deliver
the articles of impeachment to the
Senate because of this supposed terrible
imminent threat to our national security
what did they do
urgency timing is really driven by the
urgency urgency nothing could be more
urgent the urgency an urgent and urgent
there's an urgency you know to this and
we must move swiftly at the time to
screw around is it that urgency and how
Speaker Nancy Pelosi is still holding on
to the articles of impeachment urgency
urgency for which you want to
immediately remove the President of the
United States you sat on the articles
for a month the longest delay in the
history of our country they adopted them
on Friday December 13th 2019 Friday the
13th
went on vacation and finally decided
after one of their Democratic
presidential debates had finished and
after the bcs football championship game
that it was time to deliver them what
happened to their national security
interest argument wasn't that the reason
that they said they had to rush to vote
it's urgent they told us no due process
for this president it is a crisis of
monumental proportion
our national security is at risk every
additional day that he's in office they
tell us the house managers also use the
same as ski
for not issuing subpoenas for testimony
they had no time for the normal judicial
review they even complain about the
judicial review process sitting in this
chamber before the Chief Justice of the
United States Supreme Court a judicial
review in which the judge agreed to an
expedited schedule even that was not
good enough for them when they issued
the subpoenas one of the lawyers for the
subpoenaed witnesses wrote to the House
General Counsel quote we are dismayed
that the House committees have chosen
not to join us in seeking resolution
from the judicial branch of this
momentous constitutional question as
expeditiously as possible he continued
it is important to get a definitive
judgment from the judicial branch
determining their constitutional duty in
the face of conflicting demands of the
legislative and executive branches isn't
that the point isn't that how our system
of government works isn't that how it's
always worked isn't that it that how
it's supposed to work these same
Democrats defended other administrations
who fought judicial review of
congressional subpoenas and I think we
all remember fast and furious the same
attorney when he wrote to the house
chairs said the house chairman mr.
Schiff mr. Nadler are mistaken to say
the lawsuit is intended to delay or
otherwise obstruct the committee's vital
investigatory work he he continued nor
has this lawsuit been coordinated in any
way with the White House any more than
than it has been coordinated with the
House of Representatives if the house
chooses not to pursue through subpoena
testimony let the record be clear that
is the houses decision yet they come
before you and they blame the
administration and they blame you if you
don't subpoena witnesses and have them
before you yet even in the face of this
overwhelming evidence they claim that
the president is to blame for their
decision to withdraw their own
penis or not issue others their choice
but the president is responsible that is
what are their claims it is ludicrous
they are blaming the president because
they decide on their own not to seek
judicial review and enforcement of their
own subpoenas and for some witnesses
never to even issue subpoenas in their
minds that is impeachable manager Nadler
spoke eloquently back before the House
Judiciary Committee hearing in December
of 1998 he said quote there must never
be a narrowly voted impeachment or an
appeasement substantially supported by
one of our major political parties and
largely opposed by the other such an
appeasement would lack legitimacy would
produce divisive Nassim bitterness in
our politics for years to come and we'll
call it to question the very legitimacy
of our political institutions manager
Nadler was right then and it is equally
true today
divisive 'no sand bitterness divisive
Nassim bitterness listen to his words
impeachment by one party cause divisive
Nassim bitterness in our country that is
what in a partisan impeachment leads to
sadly why manager Nadler eloquently
warned against a vice eveness and
bitterness the house did not follow his
admonition they did not heed his advice
and that is one of the reasons we are
sitting here today with articles of
impeachment that are not found in our
Constitution or the evidence in our
brought simply for partisan politics
this is a sad time for all of us this is
not a time to give up souvenirs the Pens
used to sign the articles of impeachment
trying to improperly impeach our
country's representative to the world
this is not the time to try to get digs
in that the president will always be
impeached because we had the majority
and we could do it to you and we did it
to you
it is wrong it is not what the American
people deserve or want sadly
the house managers do not trust their
fellow Americans to choose their own
president they do not think that they
can legitimately win an election against
President Trump so they need to rush to
impeach him immediately that is what
they have continually told the American
people in that that is a shame we on the
other hand trust our fellow Americans to
choose their president choose your
candidate let senators that are here who
try to become the Democratic nominee try
to win that election and let the
American people choose maybe maybe
they're concerned that the American
people like historically low
unemployment maybe the American people
like that their 401k count k accounts
have done extremely well maybe the
American people like prison reform in
giving people a second chance
tellingly some of these house managers
work constructively constructively with
this administration to give Americans a
second chance that was the public
interest that is what the country
demands that's what society deserves
maybe the American people like an
administration that is fighting the
opioid epidemic maybe the American
people like secure borders maybe the
American people like better trade
agreements with our biggest trading
partners maybe the American people like
other countries sharing in the burden
when it comes to foreign aid maybe the
American people actually like lower
taxes in other words maybe the American
people like their current president a
president who kept his promises and
delivered on them if you think the
Americans if you think Americans want to
abandon our prosperity in our
unprecedented success is under this
president's then convince the electorate
in their in November at the ballot
bucks do not try to improperly interfere
with an election that is only months
away based on these articles of
impeachment in your trial memorandum
that you submitted here before the
Senate you speak about the framers of
the Constitution believing that
president Trump's alleged conduct is
their quote-unquote worst nightmare and
that they would be horrified
in fact sadly sadly it is the house
managers conduct in bringing these
baseless articles of impeachment that
would clearly be there an our worst
nightmare thank you the majority leader
is recognized mr. Chief Justice I think
we're looking at a 45 minute break for
dinner
without objection so ordered thank you